maybe venture as we know it is
unsustainable the same way that you know
we as consumers in this society are
inevitably driving ourselves towards
catastrophic climate change you know
valuations only seem to be going one
direction year after year and the pie is
growing and obviously the 2019 IPO
market is probably going to get a lot of
people pretty stoked about the current
strategy that they have but seems like
at a certain point this is going to
become not sustainable and we're gonna
have to think about how to change this
up I don't know what that looks like but
I'm just gonna throw that idea out there
that maybe we're looking at the early
moments of ventures that on its feet and
it's going to have to get rebooted in
order to cope with the realities and
finances what do you think do you think
that the venture industrial complex you
can't have a venture is one thing let's
talk about the venture funds venture is
bimodal right there are people who do
very well yep and then when you pile on
more money than is can be efficiently
deployed you just got to get a lot of
terrible returns on the other end and
the distribution right so I think that's
like when you think about these demo
days the way to think about that is
there's a bunch of people who were like
I got my ten million dollars cuz I did
an angel investment that was good and
now I've got a fund and I'll write you
100k check at 20 like that I the way
that I think about it is those funds are
always gonna be starting and going out
of business and then there's gonna be
folks who are taking and maybe a more
classic approach is the way to think
about it but there are folks who can
find the value find these things early
like my strategy is go be first money in
right and help them put this thing
together because you have a great
network and I think there's a lack of
pre product market fit it's very hard to
sort of look at these things from first
principles yeah I could be wrong but I I
think that's my comparative advantage so
I'm gonna go find these things when
they're messy and early and help them
get to a point where it's obvious right
so maybe that's a good strategy maybe
it's not but it's not going to demo day
and just saying like great what's your
cap here's 50k I think that's the part
that's unsustainable so it can both be
true that we don't lazy venture it's
like lazy angel investing
versus rolling up your sleeves and doing
the work well I'll throw it out there
that even I like when you when you look
at the macro industry trends of all the
big institutional investors what is it
like the top five to eight percent maybe
ten percent are actually getting returns
year after year and the other 90 percent
or not so I mean that to me indicates
that like we are already sitting on a
fairly broken model where most of the
people out there who are raising venture
funds are not getting returns clear are
they're gonna get some level of return
and the way I look at it is a lot of
these LPS like the big ones are only
putting sub 5% into the private
companies whether it's private equity or
venture so it's probably 1% of an
endowment 2% of its risk capital yeah
and I think they're just making a bet
like what if I get into the fund where
Sequoia has whatsapp what if I get into
Chris sockos fund where he hits Ober and
Twitter you know I think they're just
looking for something to balance out
real estate in cash I don't think that
part of the market is that broken kind
of a post product market fit it's
interesting and it's changing and there
are gonna be winners and losers to me
the weird part of the market is this
seed stage where the LPS are not
institutional it's all the money that
couldn't get into those funds and it's
trying to figure out how to deploy
capital into this market you've got a
bunch of emerging managers some of whom
are phenomenal and some of whom you
won't know we're terrible for you know
two or three funds and that's just
that's the new normal in my opinion it's
not going away we're not gonna have a
contraction we're just gonna have a
bunch of new funds over and oh it's the
new you know you start a successful
company you invest in people that you
know who are known good and you don't
care what the ideas are you look like a
genius because they are good people yeah
turns out that's not the problem you
have when you run out of personal
network to invest in right then you
become a professional and you have to
think about these other things that
you're not that good at so figuring out
who are the people who are good at doing
this in the professional mode I think is
where that money will train these people
and then those people will move towards
these institutions who are happy to buy
their IRR it's very hard for people to
understand what's going on here I think
because of the amount of
startups that die and the amount of
money that's put into those failed
experiments but they also don't look at
the you know how much cash Apple or
Facebook or Google are throwing off now
you start looking at just the
profitability of those three companies
versus how much is put into venture like
those things are going to pay off
hundreds of billions and eventually
trillions of dollars in profits